hallo mein name ist luca und wir reden
heute mal mit siri ich hoffe das klappt
alles von der qualität ich habe hier so
einen dreifachen gorillapod aufgebaut
und da hinten steht noch eine kamera die
das ganze film weil wenn man mit mir
reden will geht das nicht über computer
programme die der nimmt den ton dann
irgendwie nicht mehr gedacht clever bord
ist ein bisschen aus cool deswegen
schauen wir mal was sie reader so machen
kann
hey wie gehts dir net ist auf jeden fall
es ist jetzt ein bisschen doof mit der
face kemna war zu geben aber es geht
leider nicht anders wenn ihr
irgendwelche taktik ab wie ich mit so
war sonst auf dem ganzen qualität dann
schreibt das bitte ich die kommentare
möchtest du heute abend mit mir essen
gehen siri stoffen absolut nicht um mich
hast du mich gerade dummkopf genannt
bist du behindert du hast mich dummkopf
genannt du vollidiot es kann ja sogar
das stets doch ich weiß auf bund wieso
nennst du mich dummkopf jetzt abhängig
ob schnellen okay nein du vollidiot
ich kenne dich weiterhin dummkopf
desiree heil katze da kannst du bitte
einfach deine schnauze halten darüber
habe ich noch nie nachgedacht
wäre vielleicht meine alternative ich
bin nicht sicher ob ich das richtig
verstanden habe
wäre vielleicht meine alternative alles
klar siri zurück zur fragestellung
möchtest du heute abend mit mir zu abend
essen ich hab es okay zeigte mir gerade
so 1000 restaurants an wo damit wir
hingehen will aber das habe ich jetzt
einfach mal aus gesperrt weil er sonst
sehen würdet wo ich wohne und das möchte
ich ungern
hay habe die erst im kopf was für
dummkopf serie die so nennst du mich
immer dummkopf
[Musik]
du möchtest dass ich dich erwartung kopf
schneller nein du sollst mich nicht
dummkopf nennen
dank ich muss schon drauf drückt mich
vollidiot anke siri das ist echt sehr
verantwortungsvoll und das ist auch
richtig so und ich finde das machst du
gut deswegen wollte dich fragen ob du
heute abend mit mir etwas unternehmen
möchtest du kannst nicht alles
hingekriegt alter siri ich weiß wirklich
tun
wieso bin ich denn jetzt sei ein
vollidiot wäre ich will jetzt ein
vollidiot ich will jetzt die deinen
stopp stopp stopp stopp höher auf jetzt
macht daher macht doch ende jetzt
einsatz sollte keiner unnötigen worte
enthalten ein absatz keine unnötigen
setzte kannst du die frage noch einmal
etwas kürzer stellen halt dein maul ein
okay ich habe hier oben gesagt wieso bin
ich denn jetzt ein vollidiot ihre ich
will jetzt ein vollidiot ich will jetzt
einen stopp stopp stopp stopp jetzt
macht auch und nochmals doch endlich
wahr möchtest du heute an bei mir
übernachten
gehen wir mal hier direkt auf dem habe
ich keine reine ich sollte echt wenn ich
fertig bin mit reden einfach auf den
knopf drücken weil herz hat er
verstanden
möchtest du heute abend bei wir
übernachten die mama hier direkt offen
ich sage dazu mal nicht sprichst du noch
andere sprachen außer deutsch ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob ich das richtig
verstanden habe
sie spricht nicht mal richtig deutsch
was ist 17 durch 31 83
ein richtiges mathe genie was ist 0
durch 0 ständige vor dass nur pixel und
verteilt sie gleichmäßig auf meine
freunde ich viele kekse bekommt jeder
weißt du es macht keinen sinn und das
pullman monster ist traurig weil es
keine klicks mehr gibt und traurig weil
du keine freunde hassen sie wieso wirst
du immer so gemein zu mir nicht sicher
ob ich kochte behinderte streng dich an
was ist so schwer daran nicht zu
verstehen heißt auch wir
ich wollte das video eigentlich noch ein
bisschen länger machen aber du sagst die
ganze zeit dass du mich nicht verstehst
deswegen mache ich dir jetzt hiermit ein
angebot wenn du das jetzt hier nicht
richtig verstehst dann hau ich dir so
gegen den kopf es ist 13 uhr 10